Kurt Warner joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Curtis I am good
how are you my friend - ready to roll
you ready to run yes I am Kurt okay yes
I am hold on a second I'm asking this
question wondering if there was anything
maybe I'm being a little too sensitive
because as Suze knows nobody that I know
enjoys watching me fail at a physical
feat on live television is a strong term
I just like watch struggle do it okay
you just happen to fail a lot but it's
not that I enjoy watching you fail
necessarily I enjoy watching you do it
right now what would Brenda say if
somebody went after you like that oh yes
Brenda Warner that I know oh my gosh my
wife loves to watch me fail she loves
you but you're right it's it's that you
know that whole mothering thing right
and laugh at it yeah but but again I
just I enjoy it and when the thing about
it is that it's more exciting to watch
him succeed and then it's fun to watch
him fail you know so every time he does
it I'm like okay this is the time where
he's going to this is give me the mom
you know run a double move on Rod
Woodson and make a catch in the dome I
mean I remember those moments I mean I
do remember the you know the dunk tank
as well where this all really started
but I just I just enjoy watching you
have fun the dunk tank to which kurt is
referring was we did this on game day
morning where a handful of us were
sitting in a dunk tank and I had to
accurately throw a football to get
somebody dunked and I missed miserably
and that's where things started with
Kurt and then every single time I
actually succeed at it you I got a WoW
you know I get like the higher register
like hey you know I mean at some point
at some point that's just gonna be the
norm you're right it's just it's not
there yet but yes at some point it's
gonna be the norm man a nice snag when I
threw that ball to you across the studio
this year that's right I mean there are
definitely moments though on
you know it's but it's not gonna be
nearly as much fun when it's just you
make the play every single time I have
flashes is basically what you see you
definitely have flashes I appreciate
that and I am plant preparing to run
right now the running in terms of
fundraising is going gangbusters which
I'm very happy about and awesome
thank you sir and I know you were one of
the most philanthropic people that I
know and you inspire me to do all that
stuff so a thank you for being here on
the show let's uh answer that poll
question yes sir oh yeah you you well
what did you say trade him is that we
you so I should take borough take borrow
well I mean again it to me it's we
always talk about it's a quarterback
driven League it's all about the
quarterback position if you don't have
one you don't really have a chance to
win it outside of you know one of those
special seasons where everything else
comes together you got to find that guy
and again there are some questions with
Joe borough just from the standpoint of
he's done it for one year but that one
year was so phenomenal there's so many
things to like I was actually just
watching a little more of tua just now
and I really like to as well I mean I
think to has a chance to be a really
really good quarterback to you there's
so many things well I just don't know if
you can you know use the number one take
on to adjust with the questions about
the hip and so to me you're in the
number one spot you've got a couple
quarterbacks out there that appear to be
guys that can be a franchise guide the
next level you have to get one of those
guys and so I just think the safer pick
right now is Joe Berlin and I think he
got to go that route well I think he
handled his business very well today I
don't know if you're hurting in the
sound bites that he he said from podium
number three for those scoring at home
where he said that you know he's a
player so he's gonna show up where he's
drafted and he's gonna go and part of
the reason why he said that he had
leverage as he had no idea whether
somebody was gonna actually take him
first overall even though saying the
word leverage would mean he didn't want
to be first overall but not to dig too
deep I think he handled himself very
well today and III think that he might
have earned himself I'm going overall
pick that said to a said he's medically
cleared to start performing and
and getting out there and being
evaluated on March 9th so that means
that there's time for him to maybe show
everybody the hips not an issue Kurt no
doubt I still think there's going to be
concerns there even if he shows up you
know in shorts and you know throws
against the air and looks really good I
think they're still going to be you know
questions there about the hip and so
that's that's my worry but yeah I
thought Jo handled it extremely well and
I'll just say having you know been on
some teams that didn't have a lot of
high expectations when I got there that
was one of the most fun parts of being a
competitor was being able to say eh I
know nobody expected anything of me or
expect anything of us and being able to
help turn those organizations around so
people looked at them differently
believed differently and I think shows
something about who you can be as a
winner and as a leader and so you know I
loved when Baker last year or a couple
years ago you know got up there and said
I want to be picked by the Browns and
I'm gonna be the guy that changes things
that to me is what I love to see in my
quarterback and the competitors on my
team and so I love the Jo went out there
today and just said hey I am gonna play
for whoever drafts me I'm a player
that's what I do and I'm gonna go make a
difference wherever I'm at well I you
know Curt won here in the Rich Eisen
show I'm assuming that the Burroughs
story in being you know obviously was
highly recruited and he went to Ohio
steel Ohio State but he didn't get the
opportunity that he needed and he made
the most of the opportunity that he got
which obviously is something that you
personify when when the combine was
happening when it was time for you to
what was that like for you I've never
you know I mean for me I was just hoping
to get an invite that I thought I had
done enough in my one year to just get a
chance can right was that was my story
was right you just got one year to play
and you hope you do enough that you can
get in front of all the scouts
unfortunately I didn't get that invite
but yeah I'm always excited about guys
like that that you know bounce around
and can't find the right fit and then
they get an opportunity and they they
seize it you know and ironically enough
when I played for the Barnstormers Joe's
dad was our defensive back coach
defensive coordinator when I was with
the Barnstormer so I've known
humberto for a long time and so I'll
follow Joe throughout the year and been
in contact with him and his dad a little
bit so I'm extremely excited for the
family and where he's put himself and I
met him at the Super Bowl and got to
talk to Joe a little bit and just think
that he carries himself the right way
and I'm excited just to see not only
where he goes but more importantly what
kind of career he has well and then you
know there's there's other quarterbacks
that are out there who's out there that
we're hearing so much about jordan loves
innate athletic ability and how he has
potential mahomes type athleticism and
he's had the biggest hand size we all
know about Justin Herbert who have you
also been seen on on film tape that's
flashing - yeah probably the other guy
that flashed for me is Jacob Eason that
again the hard part is I don't
necessarily get a chance to go back and
watch the entirety of a season for all
of these guys so you kind of pick some
games here and there to watch and he was
a guy that jumped out at me I think
physically he's got talent he had you
know some games where I just thought he
looked really good and you know may move
him up ahead of some of these other guys
like the Jordan loves and the Justin
herbert's
of the world but then there were some
games where he wasn't quite as good so
there's some consistency issues I think
with you know all three of that second
tier group of guys you know Joe and - I
put them kind of up at the top really
liked them and then Jordan and Justin
and Jacob are three guys that I go I
could see them kind of getting shook up
depending on you know what your flavor
is what you like Jordan love I thought
it was much better in 2018 I watched him
in 2019 and I wasn't really a lot of
inconsistencies there and up and down
and wasn't sure what everybody was
seeing and then I had a lot of people
tell me well go back and watch him in 18
when he was in a different system and I
went back and watched it and they were
right he was so much better more
consistent more in control of what he
was doing I would probably put him third
on the board and then Herbert yet has
some flashes but I'm a guy that believes
you got to have some of the
fast-twitch be able to see and react and
get the ball out and that's something
that he struggles with he's more of a
kind of slow twitch guy and everything
takes a long time to develop even though
you know he's got some physical ability
so I think those three guys is going to
be interesting who falls in love with
one of those guys what it is about them
and and where they end up don't Kurt
Warner here on the Rich Eisen show and
then once the combine is over then we
turn our attention to the free agency
front and what a for I mean look I think
the Brady conversations gonna start
heating up this week there's already
reports that he and the Patriots are
gonna meet with one another what do you
think is going on in Tom Brady's head
your best guess well I mean I like that
he's exploring things I mean maybe more
so as an analyst than anything because
it's fun for us to speculate on all of
that stuff I still believe that the best
fit for him is New England a comfort
zone with a defense that he's knows is
going to be a top 10 defense yes I know
they've got some moving parts
offensively and some young guys and it
didn't all come together last year but
even with all of that they were
extremely successful last year and now
if they just get a little bit better
offensively I believe that puts them in
a position you know to compete again and
that to me is what Tom Brady was I just
understand when you go somewhere else
there can be a learning curve there and
that to me is what I look at with Tom
Brady and I go does he have enough time
a to be able to bring another team to
that level because when you know I
talked to him this year you know his
biggest thing was he just knew when they
went out on Sunday afternoons that they
couldn't compete at the standard of the
level that he was used to competing and
that was the hardest thing for him this
past year with the Patriots there's no
guarantee that he shows up somewhere
else even if the team is maybe better
offensively and they play up to that
standard either so does it take a year
or two to get there and how much more
time does he have so I just think the
best fit is still in New England but man
would it be fun to see him go compete
somewhere else and you know where is
that you know do you do you choose a an
LA Chargers
or an Oakland Raider team where yeah
maybe a little bit better offensively
than what you had but you got to compete
against Patrick mahomes twice a year you
know one thing about the Patriots for so
long is they win their division and it
puts them in a great position to compete
in the playoffs then you go and have to
compete against Patrick l'homme one side
of that is great we've got to beat the
best but the other side is well it's
going to be a lot harder to get in one
of those top seeds when we got to
compete against the Super Bowl champs
and so all that stuff is so fascinating
to me and as you know we're waiting for
one of those chips I guess to fall and
see you know what happens there with Tom
Brady and then how does that shake up
the rest of the rest of teams that are
looking for a guy well I guess then
maybe that's why that there's that that
constant rumor as well as some of the
reporting Jeff Darlington of ESPN
reporting it on Adam Schefter spod cast
which he said when he was on the show
last week that the Titans are a good
spot or frontrunner spot and then
there's the Colts Kurt I mean you know I
understand that would be if you're if
you're taking the approach that it's
just tough to see Brady in another
uniform or he will find it tough to be
in another uniform the latter one would
think it would be you know something
that he would have trouble grasping
walking into a building with Peyton
Manning's statue in front of it but it
just seems to me that if you want to
talk about a division where obviously
deshaun Watson is no slouch but you you
know Patrick mahomes is the reigning
Super Bowl MVP that you don't want to
face twice a year that that the AFC self
might be you know okay same conference
he could maybe potentially have New
England coming to his house or vice
versa to go that you know better than
most about playing in a dome and that's
that's no you know criticism thing you
know I mean he's forty some odd years
old he could play eight of his games in
a dome right well nine nine because
we're including Houston too so that
sounds like a good spot there no I mean
I don't think there's any doubt I mean I
think there's a lot of things I love
Frank Reich I love what he does
offensively I think Tom obviously makes
that team better I would just say do you
think that team
team that missed the playoffs last year
do you think you at your age as great as
Tom Brady's Ben are you the difference
maker that gets this team to
championship level quickly because once
again we got to remember the age here
what are we talking in or do we really
think you know two years two more years
do we think it's three or four you know
and what are you willing to go through
in that process to to help build a
championship tight team now the Titans I
think is definitely intriguing because
of where they went last year and how
good they were last year but I think a
lot of things went right for the Titans
last year I'm not sure you just line
them up every year and you say oh this
is a team it's a AFC Championship team
I'm not sure that's the case with their
talent level across the board even
though they had a phenomenal year last
year okay and then some more news coming
out of the combine that we'll talk about
still to come on this show is Bruce
Arians saying that you can win with
Jameis but that they're going to wait to
see what who might be out there in free
agency before making a decision on on
bringing him back even though you may
have to tag him before free agency
there's there's a lot at play here what
do you think about Winston inflorescence
I love Jameis you know I've gotten to
know Jameis and I think there are so
many good things about Jameis it but if
he just turned on the film football-wise
I would tell you that he makes more
plays and good reads
than probably 90% of the guys in this
league the problem is is being able to
decipher those other plays that we
always talk about right knowing what is
a good throw and not a good throw and
putting the ball in harm's way because
it doesn't matter how many plays you
make and the 5,000 yards and the 30
touchdowns and all that I mean if you're
throwing that many interceptions it is
tough to win consistently and so he's
got to figure that out and I'm sure
Bruce Arians is saying man yeah we can
win with this guy I mean look at all the
great plays that he makes but is there a
guy that can make those plays and not
make as many mistakes and allow us to be
more successful
because last year they had a really good
run defense they've got some playmakers
on the outside of course and they
probably feel they're closer to a
playoff team than they performed last
year and a lot of that because of
Jameson's mistakes but I really like
James I don't think there's a lot of
guys out there they're gonna make nearly
as many plays for you but if you get one
of these guys I mean maybe it's a
Phillip Rivers maybe it's you know a Tom
Brady and maybe it's a Derek Carr if Tom
Brady goes there I mean you know I think
there's some guys that you might be
intrigued by to say hey with our pieces
and where we're at this guy maybe give
us a better chance to win just because
there's still that unknown if Jameis is
ever going to get over the hump and be
able to eliminate those mistakes I mean
Bridgewater's out there to Kurt yep yeah
Teddy Bridgewater but again you know
Teddy Bridgewater does he fit what Bruce
Arians likes to do you're asked once
your escrow first you're asking that
question is if you already have the
answer you don't think it's I mean I
love Teddy and I think he does a lot of
things well but I still think he is more
of a complimentary piece as a
quarterback at least from what I've seen
up to this point then a guy that goes
out and carries a team with his right
arm now that doesn't mean you know
getting the right system that he can't
be that guy it's just been what you know
we've seen from him whether he was in
Minnesota or even last year it wasn't so
much about him dropping back and
throwing 35 or 40 times and winning
games for you which is what Coach Ariens
wants to do so love teddy as a leader
and as a winner and I think there's some
great spots for him to to fit in just
not sure he is that key cog that says
there's a franchise guy that we can win
by him throwing the football you know
game in a game out I curtsy a Thursday
night wait for it we'll be out there on
the field with the quarterbacks be down
there I'm looking forward to it so you
made the combine ker finally after all
these years you'll take it any way you
can get it I know you take carries all
right take your trainin you got out okay
brother well that's Kurt Warner for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on VR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app